welcome back to New rockstars I'm Eric
Boss and this is a breakdown of Star
Wars and or episode three in which we
all learn what a reckoning sounds like
it sounds like your neighbor doing
construction on a weekend morning you
wanted to stop with it but it keeps
coming in 7 15 do you have to jackhammer
your driveway right now now my Easter
egg breakdowns of episodes one and two
are on the channel right now as is our
Wikileaks reaction to the first three
episodes and in this video I am gonna
break down episode 3 shot by shot for
all the subtle details he might have
missed and yes some Star Wars Easter
eggs because there are actually some
Easter eggs to find in the series if
you're willing to actually dig for them
and not expect Easter eggs to be handed
to you on a silver platter because
Easter eggs aren't supposed to be hard
to find by definition and sometimes
these stories are just cool little
things the director put in the episode
to set up something cool that pays off
later on anyway the opening and or title
music has now evolved slightly from last
episode to include composer Nicholas
Patel's percussion
[Music]
this is what he uses to take us back to
the qunari flashbacks like we heard at
the end of episode one
then we cut to a shot peering from
Darkness at an octagonal hatch this is a
popular type of framing like Jordan
Peel's nope opens this way and you may
remember the final shot of Lost season
one when the camera drops down into that
hatch actually this octagon is giving me
major Dharma Initiative PTSD but you
know that's just me I know I mean I'm
cuckoo or even shotshik Redemption when
the warden discovers the hole behind
that poster this type of framing is
often meant to show Dangerous Discovery
as if characters are crawling down the
lens of the very camera we're shooting
this through and as they descend into
this Darkness their worlds will be
forever changed the latter rungs on the
left to tell us that this hatch was
supposed to be vertical but the ship has
rolled on its eye Casa's shoes are
stuffed with Rags so that they'll fit
better really all these kids clothes
seem scavenged from others suggesting
that they might have been the kids of
the workers who died in that pits mining
disaster whatever it was the crew of the
ship has yellow skin for the poison
yellow gas that causes crash their
uniforms are marked with the separatist
hexagon sigil so again these guys seem
to at least based on their clothes have
one and two show some allegiance to the
Confederacy of independent systems
during the Clone Wars or maybe they're
not separatists I'll get into why later
Casa sees his reflection on the glass
surface perhaps the first time in years
he has seen his reflection flooding in
with memories from before he was an
orphan also suggesting that the kid has
never looked in a freaking puddle yet
when he strikes the surface the scene
edits to the present day ferric's
scrapyard making it look as though
cass's staff caused the ship's bulkhead
to drop off concept art suggests this is
part of a republic vinegar class Star
Destroyer so Barrack's dysfunction is
too disassemble Republic era spacecraft
were parts to repurpose for the Imperial
Fleet I just love the attention and
Detail in these wide shots each of the
workers on a scaffolding he could see
the molten lines and the metal to show
where they are detaching load-bearing
points and as Cassian tells Brasso that
he's leaving this planet you can see
this lifter Droid ambling behind him as
Lutheran shuttle lands there's one Droid
whose job it is to just be steps
oh my God now at this terminal rfu
protocol droids with red and yellow
plating matching the shuttles and much
of the Wardrobe on this planet as
Lutheran strolls into town there's one
doofus who just hops off a two foot
ledge I don't know maybe he's expecting
that stair Droid and he panicked and
freaked out it turned into like an NPC
bluthing connects with Bix be more
enforcement to put out a bulletin last
night for someone needing casting's
description I've seen it the bulletin
doesn't matter by name it says they're
looking for someone for Canary
is impaired prison record says he's from
Fast yeah so it sounds like Lutheran has
definitely done his homework on who
Cassie
Cass background really is suggesting
that he may have had his eye Cassian for
quite some time the primor docking ship
arrives from hyperspace and immediately
releases three Tech pods that Barracks
surface no time at all spent between
that hyperspace arrival and the attack
mod release because mosque incarn do not
want to waste a second B2 emo rolls down
the street and a passing cart wipes the
frame to a flashback of a younger newer
more polished b2emo who doesn't stutter
in this past concentration
a younger Marva and her partner Clem
sabotaged his ship in order to steal
some console units and fuel modules and
they find young Casa destroying a lot of
that he speaks some Canary at them
he doesn't understand you now my buddy
Tommy actually spoke to Fiona Shaw about
the qunari language and she revealed
that it was a real language with
functional grammar that the child actors
all had to learn and that the adult
actors were deliberately not told what
any of it meant in your script did they
give you an idea of what cassium was
trying to communicate to you was there
was there language in there or was it
always just kind of supposed to be built
up that you guys didn't have a common
understanding but what's astonishing is
a Heritage language they did write a
language and the language as a grammar I
don't understand it sorry
but uh you know they did use the
language that they invented and so it's
a free language with bits of other
languages that might have occurred into
the future and become elected okay B
reports Republic Cricket approaching so
confirm this is during the Clone Wars
making it even more weird that the
records in episode 2 would label qunari
as an imperial mining disaster so
something else must have happened on
this planet at a later point in history
now above the attackpod door that drops
down is orabesh translating to caution
and notice how Karn gets this stink face
from the worker and he actually does a
double take to see that worker still
stink-facing at him this is really his
first encounter of a local absolutely
hating his presence Tommy also spoke to
actor Kyle Soler who said that he took
inspiration from troopers from real
world history between the world wars got
swept up in these political movements
perhaps referring to the Nazi Brown
Shirts who would Patrol streets
overzealously just like his character
does I I did look in between the world
wars about people who were committed to
or or swept up you know in a cause for a
cause for a belief system that
you know it starts out quite
um innocent maybe quite yeah you know
natural and then all of a sudden
something happens where
you didn't realize you crossed the line
now back at the flashback Marva and Clem
argue about whether to bring Casa with
them B get me the drowser
he's got people here yeah yeah we've
just killed a republican officer it'll
be open season here at the moment that
figured land sure why Marvel would say
Republic officer being the one that
those kids blue darted when the crew of
this ship are definitely wearing
separatist crests like you gotta imagine
the customer would know what that sigil
is I don't know maybe the crew is part
of a Republic's sting operation you know
Star Wars characters are always
disguising themselves as the baddies I
would just be fascinated to know what
that crew was all about and how Marva
and Clem were able to put a smoke bomb
on it Karns men raid marva's home doing
B dirty where's cash Android
power supply no don't let them scare me
they can't do that
is dude especially when he gets their
line requires extra power from B and
likely so does feeling fear a huge thank
you to Disney Emoji Blitz for sponsoring
today's video you can go ahead and
download that game for free using the
link below on your mobile device or
tablet loving Match 3 games is tough on
the one hand you get so many to choose
from on the other hand you have too many
to choose from for me Disney Emoji Blitz
stands out from the pack Disney Emoji
Blitz is unlike any other Match 3 game
on the market each Emoji has its own
unique power up and you control what to
use offering a strong layer of strategy
to each game you play and there are a
ton of emojis to choose from with a deep
collection of Disney Pixar Star Wars IP
and new characters added every week and
month lots of different Emojis with
different categories silver gold rainbow
exclusive as well as story and villain
emojis my favorite emoji of course is
Anakin Skywalker because one Star Wars
and two check out this awesome power up
who doesn't love a chance to get a quick
pod race in mid-match as you play Disney
Emoji Blitz you'll earn emojis that you
can send to your friends the download
link acts as a Creator code so anything
you spend in game will help support new
rock stars give it a click to download
Disney Emoji Blitz and start building
your collection that dummy casting gives
away his position by using the comms he
insisted that b carry meanwhile Cassian
barters with luthin over that star path
unit you can track every Imperial
coordinate for nine radial Parsons par 6
uses a unit of distance of course but
it's interesting how the star path unit
only works one time when you plug it in
otherwise its seal is broken and
presumably the coordinates either get
scrambled or the Empire gets alerted
that it was used but luthin is
definitely less interested in the unit
than he is in the person who could steal
it I went in and got this myself oh
how's that possible it was it was sealed
on the Imperial Naval base and steer
guard this tells us that Lutheran
knew that this unit isn't that valuable
to him and he might have actually set up
as a kind of golden ticket to get stolen
as a test in order to recruit quality
candidates for the Rebellion Cassian
explains how he infiltrates the Empire
they just walk in like you belong
they're so proud of themselves they
don't even care
they're so fat and satisfied they can't
imagine it someone like me would ever
get inside their house
walk their floors spit in their food
take their gear it's
fascinating the indictment of the Empire
that we've all been feeling at this
point but also characterizes Cassie and
so perfectly for Lutheran the disdain
and his Loathing in the way he describes
Imperial officers that's exactly the
language that Luther needs to hear he's
ready to recruit this guy right now it's
also interesting how Cassian seems less
afraid of the Empire than he is of the
local authorities maybe because he knows
that the Empire are so arrogant and
detached whereas the local cops like
Cyril Karn are ambitious have something
to prove and our people you got to worry
about Lutheran kind of goes off on a
tangent here these days will end
cassianander way they laugh the way they
push through a crowd the sound of that
voice tell me to stop to go to move I
don't need to die rings in the air
doesn't it soon enough well that's
something else to listen to yeah he ends
up foreshadowing how the triggering
sound of Imperial orders will be
replaced by the sound of the Reckoning
of this episode Lutheran goes on oh that
hang me wouldn't they
Take Me Out bricks Road and hang me in
the Square
wouldn't be the first time would it is
that where they hung your father yeah
Luther hence that Clem cassian's Foster
father might have been hung in the the
street for some unspecified crime again
Lutheran did his homework and might have
added Cassie into a short list when that
actually happened but think about it
criminal children have publicly executed
thieves make pretty good candidates for
Rebels Solomon runs over to this medal
to alert everyone else in town
forming a signal for all the town's
people to join in with a candid people
in neighborhoods alerting the arrival of
cops by yelling things like 505-0 if you
think about it all of this hammering on
metal is inspired by the Bell Tower at
the center of this town the way that
time Grappler announced curfew is the
same way that they all unite now
Lutheran realizes Cassian was carrying a
com link and gave away their location
rule number one
never carry anything you don't control I
like this give it some rules luton's
already begun training Cassian in the
rules of be a spy later he shares the
next rule rule number two build your
exit on your way in brace yourself we
actually see how casting applies both
those rules in his opening scene in
Rogue one having an exit ready to go in
the alleyway and killing off his
informant who would only slow him down
and make him lose control of that
situation we also see how resourceful
Lutheran is lasting a chain crank to
snare one of the Blues by using the
counterweight of the Machinery outside
the cops are scrambling
there's no signs I don't know what
street yeah removing the signs so
invading forces don't know how to
navigate is common gorilla tactic used
recently by Ukrainian forces removing
road signs to confuse the invading
Russians Tim gets shot by a cop that cop
gets sent back to the tackpod to get it
warmed up this is a guy who faces truly
the most vicious death so you know good
riddance Marva taunts the cops that are
stationed with her kids too doesn't it
shut it that's what a reckoning sounds
like you wanted to stop but it just
keeps coming I told you to shut up
during this we see Brasso walking away
from the tackpot and removing his gloves
indicating that he was the one who
sabotaged it notice later he actually
uses one of the cables that he and the
other workers were tugging out of the
piece of heavy machinery in their
earlier scene at the beginning of the
episode so this way anyone could argue
that the primor guys just stupidly
parked their attack pod on a scrap field
and didn't pay attention to what they
were parking on it could have gotten
entangled in the perk
Marva goes on it's when it stops
and you really want to start to fret why
what happens then
yeah she doesn't say but the implication
is clear when it stops it means all the
people who were clinging are now in a
position to attack you see that as soon
as the cleaning stops cassian's Blaster
is now at the back of karn's head drop
the weapon and we did see this earlier
in the shootout but I just love how
cassian's Blaster clicks and
mechanically locks into load again this
gun is the k-16 Briar pistol from the
dark Forces game carried by Kyle katarn
who at least inspired the character of
Cassian Andor when they created him for
rogue one just the reloading quality of
this pistol makes me want to go back and
play Dark Horses notice how the first
thing Cassian does here is Crush corin's
conlink showing how he has been learning
from Lutheran's rules now that pilot
gets dragged by the cabled machinery and
attack pod slams into the frame that
props put them behind us
[ __ ]
we're under siege they're everywhere
here in Star Wars though the word [ __ ]
did appear in written form and e.k
Johnston's y a book means Peril then we
see Andor applying the second of
Lutheran's lessons build your exit on
the way in do this so by rigging this
dummy speeder with explosives to draw
their fire so that he and Luther can
escape on a faster speeder Cyril card
humiliated watches his Ambitions burn in
front of him the blues that he brought
in here are now wounded and they shout
backed up over into the Star Wars
healing fluid that comes in tanks and in
spray form they yell back to the way one
would medic now I love this little then
whistles to Signal his hallcraft to
power up and this final sequence
intercuts between cassian's heart escape
with Luton and casts as hard escape with
Marva and Clem and with bertel's score
it is just heartbreaking it feels like
it is part of the same escape a
character always on the run never really
feeling the Comforts of Home Clem loads
the stolen Parts in a hidden compartment
that's under that checkerboard tile
telling us that this is the same ship
that Cassian has been using all this
time in the same compartment where he
hid the Imperial star path unit sunlight
beams in them and she turns around to
check on the waking Casa on the same cot
where we saw Cassian sleeping in episode
one but instead of the face of the young
kid looking back at her the editing cuts
the reaction shot of adult Cassian a
mother and son drawn back together
across time and I just love that the
light glows brighter and brighter on
cassian's face as if he's getting an
extra glow from somewhere maybe through
time the source will notice that young
cast has shielded his eyes from the
glare and night glare might be coming
from marva's ornament hanging from the
same spot in her cockpit where Han Solo
would keep his famous golden dice in the
Falcon cockpit a glare from the prism in
the center of that ornament in the same
shape of a kyber crystal just like the
one jyn urso kept with her in Rogue one
and yes that ornament still appeared to
hang in marva's cockpit when Cassian was
in there in episode 2 so really the most
valuable thing Cassian owns might remain
in the home that he just left behind I
love this series so much and my
breakdowns of episodes one and two are
currently on the channel so check those
out if you haven't already follow me on
Tick Tock Instagram and Twitter at avos
follow new Rockstar subscribe to new
Rockstar for more analysis of everything
you love thanks for watching bye
[Music]